le jeu est simple les meilleurs le sont
toujours
vous voulez survivre respecter les
règles la victime a été identifiée
c'est la pièce d'eau potable jégo est
mort de plus de 10 en famille ces spots
à on a trouvé ça sur le corps la vérité
vous libérera
flo
à
on court après amor
que trois
imitateur
je
vivre ou mourir
je suis à vous de choisir tiens
vous savez ce qui se passe si on ne
respecte pas les règles le sens trouvée
sous les ongles de notre victime et
celui des djeun kramer était le tueur au
puzzle
c'est impossible
il est dit que c'était un jeu
on peut gagner
c'est juste ça
non c'est pas le fait pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]